eu estava fazendo quase completando 50
anos pode até não parecer mas eu estava
naquele momento é onde eu me olhava e o
sentimento que eu tinha era que eu
estava usando roupas velhas roupas
apertadas cuidas desconfortáveis
mais do que isso eu tinha aquela
sensação de que eu às vezes até usava
roupa dos outros
mesmo se eu tivesse no guarda roupa
algumas roupas novas e eu ia lá escolhi
as familiares
isso estava me causando um sofrimento eu
nasci no interior do rio grande do sul
numa cidade pequena chamada passo fundo
no pátio de casa no quintal que era
enorme
tinha uma grande churrasqueira onde os
domingos eu fazia churrasco meu pai tava
ali ao redor do fogo e na infância foi
muito feliz
autêntica simples e entre árvores e
assados
eu era um sentido um pouco diferente eu
buscava ouro no parte do vizinho e eu
sonhava com discos voadores e
teletransporte influenciada por um
seriado da época que eu adorava chamados
seres da manhã
mal sabia eu que naquele pátio ao redor
do fogo com o meu pai estava a minha
essência e algo que mudaria minha vida
eu venho de uma longa jornada
viajei o mundo mas nos últimos tempos
quando eu tentava buscar a minha verdade
e conectar com a verdade a única
resposta que eu escutava era essa a
verdade está fora da área de cobertura
eu adoro histórias e de minha vida
também viajando para lá e para cá
tentando buscar repertórios porque eu
achava realmente quando tivesse filhos e
netos
eu queria ter histórias boas para contar
para eles na verdade eu não tive filhos
nem netos mas eu tenho oito sobrinhos
que hoje me chamam de tia maluquinha e
as minhas irmãs
eu tenho três irmãs já tentaram fazer
uma biografia não autorizada sobre a
minha vida pra vocês terem uma idéia
vou contar uma história pra vocês então
que aconteceu comigo
alguns anos atrás eu fui fazer uma
viagem para o sul do chile com uns
amigos e bem no dia do meu aniversário é
2 de janeiro nós resolvemos subiu vulcão
vila rica
o vulcão villarrica eu não sei qual é a
altura do vulcão mas eu sei que para
chegar lá demoravam às 8 horas
subi com grupo um guia e jogava umas
cinco horas de subida quando acabou a
dar minhas forças e eu tentava me
concentrar buscando aquela força física
mental e concentrando naquelas pessoas
que superam os desafios mais difíceis
mas vamos ter não deu eu tive que parar
e desistir
eu tive que aceitar meus limites mesmo
sentindo derrotada triste frustrada
comigo eu fiquei parado ali
o guia por ser no dia do meu aniversário
ele ficou do meu lado eu não sei quanto
tempo a gente ficou ali mas ali eu tive
que parar e sentir não tinha outro jeito
senti aquela força do ar rarefeito do
vento e do frio mas sim aquela paisagem
deslumbrante que me inspirou para
continuar a subida e eu falei pro guia
vamos continuar
e aí ele por ser meu aniversário pegou
na minha mão
graças a deus e juntos a gente conseguiu
chegar até o cume
então eu tava assim mais ou menos nessa
situação na minha vida naquele momento
eu precisava parar
precisa parar para me sentir de verdade
pra mim olhar para dentro para deter
expectativas parar de olhar para fora e
precisava colocar minha vida em ponto
morto simplesmente um ponto morto e
deixar a paisagem da vida se revelar
entender que estava sentindo
foi bem difícil e as contas chegando o
coração apertado de saudade
a vida lá fora andando muito rápido como
geralmente é mas eu não tinha outro
jeito eu tinha que parar e olhar e
escutar porque senão eu ia ser de novo
colocada num treino entrando em um
trilho que não era meu e que tem hora e
estação para descer
nesse momento nessa situação de vida é a
memória da infância dos momentos ao
redor da churrasqueira e do fogo com o
meu pai
se tornaram cada vez mais vivas na minha
trajetória também os momentos onde
estava com os amigos com a família com
colegas ao redor do fogo fazendo
churrasco se tornaram mais vivos também
e disso vê vieram algumas perguntas
importantes que eu comecei a me fazer
porque a churrasqueira não é o lugar da
mulher
por que não colocar à frente dessa
gastronomia espetacular que é o
churrasco e por que ela se limita no
forno fogão e não aproveitam todas as
potencialidades da sua etnia do fogo que
tem a churrasqueira e como um raio
fulminante assim a resposta veio eu vou
ensinar as mulheres a fazer churrasco
tem que ensinar eu sei não é ensinar é a
sentei na verdade e me tornei a
churrasqueira
feliz da vida
eu estava eu e quebrar o preconceito
porque esse preconceito em relação à
mulher não é só no rio grande do sul na
verdade no mundo inteiro em qualquer
lugar no item independe de classe social
na verdade é isso aqui por exemplo uma
foto que eu tirei um pouco tempo atrás
eu estava andando de carro em rumo ao
centro a rodoviária de porto alegre para
tirar sua foto em baixo de um viaduto
vocês verem que não se trata de uma
questão de classe social mas uma questão
cultural mulher ali dentro da caixinha
esperando ficar pronto o estudo e também
aqui vou passar um vídeo de uma aluna
minha
olha que ela respondeu meu pai pra
ninguém
fazer uma coisa que seu homem é porque
nós já temos uma experiência grande
homem
na verdade o que sabe a mulher que não
quis aprender alguma coisa para que seu
nome é o xuxa é cultura e tem mais agora
desse vídeo da de uma aluna minha que ao
ser convidada por uma amiga para ir no
curso
olha o que ela disse é hora do churrasco
e trocar um pneu de carro no aluno o
diploma de mulher
como não tinha completamente nada a
perder comecei a fazer o projeto do
curso fez um plano do curso eu ia fazer
alguma coisa que eu ia que eu amo fazer
me diverti demais então só que é o
seguinte eu sei fazer churrasco mas não
sabe ensinar como é que eu ensinar
eu tive que olhar pra dentro buscar
entender todos os processos e rapidinho
o curso estava pronto o projeto estava a
minha cara tava simples autêntico estava
usando a minha roupa e e aquilo pra mim
fazia todo o sentido do mundo eu estava
encontrando a primeira imagem que eu
usei para o meu curso foi essa queda de
8 na até que tem que ter tem que ser
faca na bota como a gente diz lá no sul
para fazer o primeiro curso eu busquei
um ex vizinho de prédio foi o dono de
uma churrascaria uma uma casa de
grelhados muito especial de porto alegre
chega pra ele apresentou o projeto e ele
imediatamente banco a ideia ea gente
marcou uma data e começou publicitário
de formação trabalhou na área de
comunicação eu sabia como fazer
acontecer então rapidinho a turma votou
e teve muitas matérias né no jornal ea
gente eu consegui juntar no primeiro
curso 25 mulheres e mais legal é que são
mulheres de várias idades e realidades
isso me emocionava muito porque elas
estavam ali com várias histórias para
contar
tinha uma aluna minha por exemplo as
mãos na solteira que ela chegou a ligar
para os amigos pra perguntar se aprender
fazer churrasco aumentaria as chances
dela de gol e conseguir um namorado
aconteceu e aí teve outra tem uma mulher
casada é uma aluna casada que ela estava
ali na cozinha preparando a salada
arrumando as coisas do marido na
churrasqueira tomando caipirinha
conversando com os amigos e quando ela
ia chegar na churrasqueira ele estava
num churrasco pronto e pra que ela ela
aquilo era ela não tinha tempo de
aproveitar
então eu fui aprender para fazer no
ritmo dela e ela também tenha também
mais feliz né
e também tem uma aluna minha é essa que
apareceu antes falando do preconceito
que ela tinha que ela é separada ela
herdou a fumar cobertura super linda do
desse casamento onde a churrasqueira
para ela era um lugar de luto e de
tristeza porque era lá onde ela se
reunir com os amigos com a família e de
repente eu não tinha o que fazer com
aquilo ela nem frequentava mais a
cobertura mas aí ela aceitou o curso né
à reportagem ela eo pai dela falando
sobre isso sim pra mim é muito prazeroso
da churrasqueira língua canção fogo
ilegal que agora a fiel também descobrir
agora é exatamente isso saber que eu
posso botar fogo e que vai dar certo e
que eu vou servir o churrasco de
primeira pra mim pra minha filha pra
minha família e meus amigos sensacional
essa essa sensação de liberdade não
preciso de um homem preocupe poder comer
um churrasco legal né se eu quiser ele
quando eu quiser eu posso também fazer o
meu e também possa curtir o meu pai e
meus amigos todo mundo beleza do nu e
ouvindo acabe a rua são histórias assim
que fazem a gente ser feliz
eram muitas histórias muitas realidades
mas todos estavam ali por algo em comum
ocupar um lugar que não era permitido a
elas e que elas também não se permitiu
isso pra mim tem um valor inestimável
aconteceu outra mudança também lá quando
se começou a falar no assunto muitos
saíram do armário as que sabiam já fazer
churrasco apareceram várias as que
queriam aprender
câmeras e também aquelas que
simplesmente achavam que não precisavam
aprender porque elas trabalhavam semana
inteira na cozinha domingo é o dia deles
fazer um churrasco
só que ela diz que sim que ela estava
lavando louça depois fazendo a salada
rumando à mesa e assim vai
então começou a se falar sobre isso mas
principalmente o que eu senti que fazer
churrasco mesmo aquelas que já faziam se
tornou um valor é um reconhecimento
importante no meus cursos
eu busco surpreender criar uma grande
confraternização porque pra mim a
churrasqueira um lugar de união e de
informalidade de troca de idéias e
sonhos
então por exemplo eu gosto de juntar
mulheres diferentes áreas
eu chamo uma amiga padeira para fazer um
pão com alho da receita de pão com alho
umas homilia para falar sobre a
harmonização de vinhos uma especialista
em corte de procedência de carnes para
falar sobre a origem do animal e uma
carteira que eu gosto de uma gaita que
ela abre que abre a alma das
participantes
então é bem bacana e descobrir né que
ensinar que o conhecimento por mais
simples que seja ele faz ele tem um
significado pra muita gente
ele cria uma força de união através
dessa afinidade e isso pra mim foi uma
descoberta realmente muito importante
a repercussão foi muito rápida também de
repente estava dando entrevista em rede
nacional participando de programas de tv
falando sobre isso no jornal na rádio
foi muito bacana foi muito rápido tem
inclusive uma reportagem que dizê las o
churrasco como os homens nunca viram eu
achei o máximo
mas uma pergunta que sempre me faziam
era churrasqueira lugar de mulher e eu
respondi dia eu acredito que cada um faz
o que gosta independente de ser homem ou
mulher
eu por exemplo eu sei trocar pneu mas eu
não gosto
então cada um faz o que quer e uma
pergunta que me fazia o que muda o mundo
a ensinar uma mulher a fazer um assalto
chão que eu acho que se chama linguiça
né
e aí eu olho pra cara dessa o rosto
dessa minha aluna ea resposta vale um
prazer poder a muito treinamento
e outra como a como churrasqueira para
mim é um lugar de encontro de união e
confraternização
eu quero levar para as ruas vou agora
falar com essa minha amiga padeira ea
gente viu que eu quero colocar uma
churrasqueira na frente da sua calçada
ela ficou espantada no início mas me
permitiu do bota uma churrasqueira ela
traz o pão quentinho do forno ea gente
cria um sanduíche que tipo choripan
muitos enquanto a gente já teve
é uma delícia contra as pessoas ali em
volta da churrasqueira que é o que eu me
sinto bem
pessoas conhecidas e pessoas que viram
amigas só está envolta da churrasqueira
em já fez vários eventos e eu também
faço eu vou na casa das pessoas a
churrasco e o que eu gosto mais disso é
que eu consiga através dessa dessa
atividade
criar uma volta ao passado a nossa
origem primitiva onde ao redor do fogo a
gente fica contando os sonhos tocando
histórias falando sobre sobre si mesmo e
acaba sendo uma grande experiência
a churrasqueira existe né porque eu
realmente acredito que o lugar de mulher
é na churrasqueira existe um poder aí
uma de uma delicadeza e um em uma
possibilidade dessa alquimia do fogo que
é imperdível que a mulher tem todo
direito e deve participar
então eu do curso sem respiro e acho que
existe por causa disso e faz algumas
atividades gastronômicas também eu
acredito que a mulher tem uma
responsabilidade sobre essa resgate da
magia do fogo e aonde eu quero cada vez
mais proporcionar essa inspiração
todo mundo tem seus vulcões eu tenho os
meus e prometi e vou continuar tendo os
desafios mas eu sinto que quando for
preciso parar a gente para quando for
preciso a gente olhar a gente se olha a
gente pára e quando for preciso a gente
se escutar
é importante a gente parar também porque
porque o maior desafio de vencer a si
mesmo é olhar pra dentro
mas é só lá dentro que a gente pode
encontrar algo de realmente genuíno que
no meu caso foi a churrasqueira
obrigada